Alex shiny.
Wow.
[inaudible] you can here.
Yeah.
Okay.
This isn't nerve wracking.
I've done this once before.
Or you came five years ago for your first book.
Yeah,
it was super cranky.
I'm a Gemini.
That half of me was like on the porch drinking beer and I came here and people
were like,
hmm.
Most and googled talk.
Um,
so what made you ready to decide to write another cookbook?
compulsive behavior.
No,
I'm kidding.
I'm naturally not.
Um,
I'm an insomniac and I am the thank you mam.
Is that you?
Um,
I'm an insomniac.
I cook a lot.
Um,
I cook a lot at home because I have an 11 year old child.
Ava.
It was here today.
Yes.
Um,
she's forced to be there.
She looks so gracious and hospitable,
but really it's all a lie.
Um,
so I'm an insomniac.
I love to cook.
I Cook a lot at home and I think that books for chefs that are Chevy,
you know,
where your tweezing caviar on tiny little pieces of micro celery that are then
suspended in midair and they're from Switzerland.
That stuff is really daunting.
And I find that a lot more of the cooking that I actually do is at home.
Um,
and so my,
I just apply a chef sensibility to home cooking.
And so I found there was just a big body of recipes I had that really spoke to
me in that way.
And that's really how this book came about.
Yeah.
Cause it's been five years in between,
right,
because you came here five years ago.
Yes.
And a reminder of my unproductivity no,
I'm teasing.
The book is so full,
like,
yeah,
there's so much depth in it and there's so many,
so many recipes that are not daunting for someone who is not a culinary trained
person like myself.
Um,
to tackle,
I just think how much,
you know,
there's so many cookbooks in the universe.
I am the daughter of a cookbook editor.
My mother is basically the Quincy Jones of Cookie Academy and she,
um,
I just kind of said,
how many more cookbooks can we put out in the world?
And I have,
I went to Martha Stewart's last book party and I said,
wow,
a book about flowers.
Martha,
what book is this for you?
And she said,
it's my 99th book.
Wow.
And I just said,
I'm on like point 99.
Um,
so apparently there's a lot more to say.
How did you choose the recipes?
Um,
that's a good question.
You know,
uh,
just collections,
every kitchen I worked in,
I just took notes on a notepad and they're all like small,
they fit in the back pocket or,
or in the bra so you can write something down and just know chef I had to that
down.
Um,
and there were just greasy and butter stained and they have like,
you know,
the raspberry jam on them.
But I just collected all these recipes and I sort of find that the recipes pop
up in for,
you know,
in their,
in their proper order as I,
as the book unfolds.
So really I write the,
I wrote the book late at night and early in the morning everybody's sleeping and
I'm like,
Oh yeah,
I'm deep in a raspberry doughnut recipe.
And my daughter's like,
what's up?
And I'm like,
I can't talk.
The yeast is wrong.
I remember the talk I'm you did five years ago cause I was here for that.
You mentioned that your mom did the similar,
what's similar and the way she edited the cookbooks you would get up and she
would still be editing from the night before.
So twisted my,
I twisted.
Yeah.
My Mother did the 1997 revision of the joy of cooking.
So every 10 years or so the joy of cooking is revised.
Why,
why revise a book like this?
Well,
I mean when you've turtle soup and squirrel brain in a recipe in a,
in a book,
we don't kind of realize,
tastes evolve.
Um,
we now have an Instagram of,
we'll do double decker,
Turkey squirrels sandwich.
I mean,
I'm kidding,
but maybe not.
Um,
so my mother was revising this book and it took,
I mean it took almost four years of her life and I was working at a restaurant,
Danielle at the time,
and I started my shift at four o'clock in the morning,
the lunch shift.
I would start prepping lunch food at four 30 and sometimes not be set up by the
way,
just like someone would order something at noon.
And I'm like,
hmm,
to have that by the time they get back from the bathroom or their phone call.
So my,
my mom and I were on the same schedule.
I mean I would get up and she would be bent over a stack of papers at the dining
room table and I would say,
I'm going to work.
And she would just hold up a picture and say,
does this look like a mallet peck oyster?
And I'm like,
no,
you know a Mel peck is a little,
she's like,
shut up.
It's a Malpais.
So she was asking,
but she wasn't.
So I learned,
you know,
this does this look like a Belgian waffle.
I'm like,
it's a nice waffle.
She's like,
does it look Belgian?
So things got a little intense,
you know,
sleep deprivation and lack of food and oxygen and water while you're writing a
book about food and oxygen and water can get a little ironic.
What,
um,
how did you choose how to break up the chapters?
Like I saw that,
I was very curious to ask you this.
Root vegetables and the onion family got their own chapters.
You know,
I'm so sick of non-sexy vege hanging out underneath in the dark bins in the
nosebleeds of the supermarket,
like asparagus and fava beans and fresh peas and pineapple.
Right.
They're all the ones that have all this external sex appeal.
What about the unsung heroes?
What about the kind of,
bless your heart,
homely vegetables.
It really deliver.
So a lot of what the potato,
I went at the bins underneath Rutabaga,
celery root,
even mushrooms.
I mean,
I feel like they're always there and you're like,
oh,
whatever.
I'll buy mushrooms as a truffle truffle.
Right,
right.
Okay.
But you know,
they're not native to America and there are no truffles here.
So I tried also to stick with,
I love the supermarket.
I mean,
for me it's like a wonderland.
I can't,
I go to the supermarket,
I'm there for two hours,
just like,
well,
look at this.
It's really sick.
I need counseling.
Um,
I do,
I need to,
like if I go to a farm stand and a supermarket,
that's the day for me.
It's over.
Um,
so all those mushroom that,
the supermarket mushrooms that are always there,
like should talkies Kermes portobellos white.
But there's so much stuff.
So again,
there's a supermarket,
mushroom chapter.
I hate those recipes to the are like take three pounds of Porcini mushrooms
fresh from Oregon.
I'm like,
I don't have that.
How do you feel about some,
you know,
Shataka is from a parking lot in New Jersey?
Well that,
can I sub that in?
So if I'm thinking that aren't a lot of people,
we're not all Eric repairing.
No one actually is.
I put there,
I actually think he's an imposter himself.
This is just a perfect human being.
It's really upsetting.
Yeah,
he's married.
Let's move on.
So obviously you have cooked from your own cookbook.
I,
what's your Goto recipes for the week?
Um,
I'm really,
you know,
I give lots of recommendations,
but as a chef,
I,
I approach a cookbook cooking from a cookbook in a very disorganized fashion.
I think a lot of chefs do this.
I'll take a cookbook and I'll look at a pork chop and apple recipe and I will
turn it into,
it'll,
I'll make it multiple times and then the recipe will give me an idea for a Pi
and the pork chop recipe then morphs into a great pie filling that started with
something else.
So for this,
um,
I really like the Pasta recipes and I like them cause you can make them and when
they sit overnight,
after you're done eating a bunch of it in the door of the fridge really late,
I know you're not here the whole time,
then you got stuff in your fridge.
Everybody does it.
The deal door of the fridge and your underwear type of eating.
That is so delicious.
Let's be honest.
Um,
so I like those types of recipes for the snack and then maybe the next day they
taste even better.
So anything tomato base for example,
tomatoes love to be cooked and then left to sit overnight or even two days I
find their better.
And He,
I have a lot of one pot meals.
Those are great too.
And people love that.
You know,
people aren't going to spend as much time as I do cooking.
And I assume not obsessive Lee seeing food everywhere.
They look in the universe.
I mean,
literally I went to a story yesterday and I was looking at surf boards and I'm
like an ice cream sandwich shaped like a surfboard with a flared edge.
I'm all in with,
I'm thinking flavor combos of cookies and ice cream.
And then I realized that I just look creepy.
Um,
and that some people go to the store and just see a surf board.
So probably a lot of those types of recipes that are make ahead or they can sit
in the fridge.
Also,
there's a whole chapter of sauces and vinaigrettes so you can make a bunch of
those,
throw him in the,
what I call the door of the fridge.
And then you buy something,
chicken,
steak,
whatever you're feeling,
Tofu,
vegetables,
and you throw one of those sauces on it and then you feel fancy.
And then you tell people you made the whole meal yourself or just buy something
to go and just dump one of your homemade vinaigrettes on it and be like,
I crushed it.
What chefs have inspired you over the years?
I love this question.
Um,
so many,
um,
chefs,
I envy chefs.
I want to be that.
I won't be chefs.
I'm so mad at being that aren't me.
There's a lot of envy and jealousy getting a theme.
Um,
and then chefs,
I just love to some,
I love to talk,
so I'm,
I love to watch cook.
Um,
I like Anne Sophie peak a lot.
She's French.
She's got a three star Michelin and she just stands there like this,
calmly with like 700 people behind her all.
Like
I covered that kind of relationship.
I go to my own restaurant,
they're like,
what's up Ida?
He was like,
rap music blasting and they throw me like a pint container of ice water.
And I'm like,
hmm,
okay.
Uh,
it's all a matter of how you frame the picture of people.
Um,
I like,
um,
chefs I've worked for or with key Savoie who has a restaurant in Las Vegas and
in Paris.
I worked for him for almost seven years and he,
I hear his voice in my head.
I think everyone has a mentor or a boss or a colleague and that's the voice or
your mother.
If you've not worked it out on the couch,
that's where it's,
you know,
that's where it stays for a little while.
I hear his voice in my head when I'm cooking and he just,
the one thing he always taught me was do not ever throw flavor away.
If you're cooking something in a pan,
get the juices from where that fish or meat or whatever cooked and get that into
the dish and not for the dishwasher.
And so every time I'm cooking,
I always think,
how can I keep all the flavor in the room?
And so that constant reminder,
because it,
that's true.
Every time you cook something,
whether it's a slice of toast,
you're like,
collect the crumbs,
collect the good bits,
everything has,
you know,
don't leave anything behind.
And so he's a big one for me.
So shifting a bit,
um,
how did you end up on the food network?
I know.
I don't know.
I don't,
I can't believe it.
Right.
Crazy.
You're an iron chef.
Yeah,
I know.
Oh,
I saw,
no,
are you crazy town?
I get up every day.
I'm like,
my life is a complete sham,
but I am an iron chef.
What was I feeling?
Oh my God.
That,
and imagine it's on television.
I can watch one of the grid.
I mean giving birth to my child was definitely the best,
but I don't want to watch that video.
Not My sexiest,
but to watch getting that title was,
I can,
my daughter has it saved in the DVR and I'll come home every once in a while and
she's like,
check this out.
Oh,
this old thing I sold real of me be so great because you know a lot of chefs,
I don't know maybe a lot of people,
but a lot of chefs I think are a hybrid of acute arrogance and low self esteem
and no middle.
So we're like a really great donut with no feeling.
And so when you have a moment that's actual validation that you can witness,
um,
it's a,
it mixes that salad up.
And for me it did.
And,
um,
so I won and I,
all I was thinking was,
oh,
don't cry.
Like,
just please don't cry,
you know,
inside,
like don't get all like you like me,
you really let you know,
like none of the,
I just thought so I thought that.
So then I thought about,
you know,
like puppies in a meadow running in the field and flowers and cake of course.
And then Bobby flay came up to me and said,
the best thing about this is how much you deserve it.
And I just saw it.
I can die now.
I mean,
we're good.
And went home.
I did the show once and I didn't win.
Just so we're clear.
I'm talking about that.
No,
we will,
we will talk about the flawed journey.
Um,
and so they called me and they said,
you know,
we want to do a redemption,
um,
series,
will you do it?
And I said,
no,
I'm not going to do it again.
I just can't.
I can't have my heart broken twice.
Um,
many of you have dated people and broken up and been like,
I'm never talking to them again.
And then the next day you're like,
what time is dinner?
I was really like on the breakup trail with this show.
And I called my mother and I said,
they want me to do the next iron chef again.
And she said,
Oh,
don't do those competition shows.
You're so bad at them.
Snapshot Childhood damaged questions.
I'll take questions on that one.
So I did it and I,
well,
I said to the food network,
can I do it?
But can you guarantee that I win?
That's,
I think that's fair guys.
It's like a fair playing field.
I win.
Um,
and they said no.
So that didn't work.
Um,
and I remember,
um,
just my cell phone ran out of juice and I was on the street and there was like a
payphone on the corner where I live.
So I'm like half a block from my apartment,
but on the payphone with my agent like a dude.
So
every time I look at that pay phone now I'm like,
you know,
like what a dope.
But I really just thought,
if I don't do this again,
if I don't take a chance on myself again,
I won't forgive myself.
Then that opened up a lot of doors to Ben be featured more on the food network
has every time I turn the food network on your,
on everything,
I have wine guy's grocery games,
you're on beat Bobby flay or on chopped.
I'm involved with the Mafia.
Uh,
I know it's so weird.
I turn it on.
I'm like,
hi you again.
It's really hard to watch yourself.
I liked the episodes of chopped.
I enjoy them more when I'm not on them watching them.
Um,
it's,
it's really interesting for me to,
I,
every year I have a different favorite judge.
You know,
like I'm like,
look at June this year,
but every year we go to the set of chopped and say,
what are we're here again?
We can't believe it.
And then I fall into a chop marathon on my own couch.
So I'll come home from shooting chopped,
and even I'll watch four episodes and shop net net.
I never want to see Ted Allen again.
He's like,
come over for dinner.
I'm like,
no,
I'm so sick of you.
When I watched the guy's grocery games,
you,
you won on the frozen feud where you took scallops and like frozen lemon sorbet
and made some fancy dinner.
I,
how did you do that?
It was from really neurotic.
I love a supermarket.
Suicides.
Sorbet would've never think to use that in a savory dish.
Well,
that's guy.
Okay.
That's the land of guy.
It was an unbelievable human being.
Yeah.
Um,
astoundingly smart.
He's there as much as you are.
Every time I turned it on,
I'm either watching chopped or diners driving and dive.
Oh yeah.
Well he says,
you know,
I'm shooting triple d and then I'm going to triple g and I'm like,
oh my God,
you're making your way through the alphabet.
We do shows.
That show is so awesome.
I love running around a supermarket.
It's an incredible set.
It's a supermarket fully loaded and you know,
I'll catch guy in the aisle,
snacking on stuff.
He's like,
this product's really good.
So the next challenge they set us free and I just take all this stuff guidelines
and I'm like,
oh,
why do you like this,
this,
um,
I get him to open cans and jars from me while he's standing there.
He is really fun to work with.
Um,
and I loved the show so I don't know.
Something about the supermarket.
I mean it's basically chopped is a great training ground for any other
competition show for me.
And I'm so unbelievably competitive.
I mean people like,
well,
you know,
I liked this sorbet.
And I'm like,
why do you like that one better?
You know,
it takes nothing for me to get rolling.
I mean,
I'll fight you right now for this cookbook.
I'm kidding.
Sorry.
But I really competitive and it's been such a privilege to be able to compete on
TV,
um,
and call that part of what I do.
I started out on food network challenge years and years ago.
I did a Thanksgiving challenge.
We had five hours to make a Thanksgiving dinner and it filmed in Denver,
Colorado,
and I,
I had never been,
and I really didn't know about the cooking and altitude thing.
I didn't think that was real.
I'm like,
oh,
come on.
Was this silly little mountain stuff?
It makes such a difference.
I've learned about this on top chef.
Yeah.
I mean,
I tried to make mashed potatoes and it never happened five hours.
I kept believing,
you know,
they're just like,
hold on until you know the cat kitten on the branch.
Like hang in there.
That kind of poster like that.
I was the poster child for hoping that the altitude was not a reality.
So I didn't win.
And I thought,
well if you don't win,
you don't get asked to be on TV again.
But boy do they like a loser.
They were like going to Shelly,
how are ya?
I saw you last and most glorious fashion.
Are you busy?
Well,
you know,
I was at home fielding all my offers from having just lost the competition show.
So it snowballed.
I did some,
I judged some iron chef.
I met Bobby Flay,
who I,
I famously really didn't like.
I used to turn on food,
now are going to be like,
who's this guy thinks he's so cool with his grill and his spatula and his stupid
hamburgers and I couldn't have been more wrong about that.
So,
um,
I did some daytime cooking stuff and then I just chopped came along and I just,
I,
oh,
I said no to the producer called me about chopped and I said,
I don't want to be on that show.
It seems like it won't be a hit.
You think guys think my career as a TV exec is just no right?
Like no,
let it go.
Um,
and they just kept co really,
I mean I have to say there was one food network producer,
um,
exact who just stopped me and said,
just go once to the set and do one episode.
And if you don't like it,
you don't have to go back.
So I shot one episode of chopped and the floor producers said,
what do we have to do to get you to do this show?
And I said,
I always have to sit in the middle.
So I'm the only judge who always sits in the middle.
Oh,
you're a,
you're not king center square.
I used to watch a Hollywood squares.
I was like in the middle cares about the,
the,
the suburbs.
It seemed like a good move.
You know what I'm saying guys,
when you're judging,
is there anything you've been given that's been just awful tasting all the time?
Really?
Yeah.
Or wait,
let me rephrase that.
No,
nothing.
There's been a lot of awful stuff and there are a lot of ingredients that if you
didn't grow up eating them,
you don't have an understanding of them that's ingrained in you.
You cannot fake that.
Um,
I have ingredients I'm given where I'm like,
no,
I needed to start with this ingredient,
the age of 10,
either eating it or cooking it or both to really understand it.
And that's where culture is a card to play on chopped.
And if you happen to get an ingredient in the basket that that's part of your
cultural background or part of what you ate growing up,
that's a big advantage.
And that's like a luck thing in a way.
Um,
but yeah,
I've had some hideous stuff.
Oh my God.
And the worst is when the nicest person makes the worst dish and you're like,
I would love to have drinks with you,
but you're about to meet that hallway and get shot.
And that's hard.
Or when someone is an amazing chef with an incredible pedigree and doesn't have
the confidence in that context and blows it w I can't tell you how many times
we've had the,
the best cook out of the four of them,
blow it on the first round and leave two of the ingredients off and they're
like,
I know it was sitting there and you're like,
what do you like?
My whole day was based on what you are going to do.
What am I supposed to do now?
And I think that's why the judges on chopped are unique.
I think I,
I call us the cast of friends.
I think you pick like we all do with friends.
You don't know why?
Like some days you just feel chandlery.
Some days you feel Monica [inaudible] some days you're singing smelly cat.
I think people do the same thing with the chuck judges.
Sometimes we feel debonair,
a carrion.
Sometimes we feel like nebulous and strange.
Santos,
you know,
it depends on what you're vibing.
I always say Amanda Fried tag is sort of the upholder of cooking truth.
She's like,
everything you did was unbelievably creative,
but your chicken is overcooked.
And I'm like,
I,
I'm much more of like a Koombaya.
Like,
Oh,
you made a drawing a creative.
If I tilted this way,
I understand it.
Amanda goes right for the truth of the food,
you know?
So it's so interesting that mix.
How do they choose or do you know how they choose the ingredients?
It's a tub secret.
No,
it's food,
food network.
We have a whole staff of people that choose the baskets.
You can make suggestions.
Um,
you can beg and plead for things not to be in there.
but it's,
it's a,
it's a group of people,
a group of trained experts that just sit around googling things.
So step it up,
guys.
Um,
what is the best meal that you've ever had?
I know mine.
That's why I always ask people this,
God,
that takes real presence of mind to know something like that.
The best meal I've ever had.
You never had an experience where you just like,
wow,
this is,
this is like top 10.
Yeah,
I ate in a,
I lived in France for almost seven years,
almost all of my twenties.
I spent living in France and I went down to nice randomly for like a couple of
days in the Riviera and there was a little hole in the wall.
It's not really a hole in the wall,
but it's small and very homey.
Beasto they don't have phones and they have just communal tables with these very
uncomfortable little stools.
And the wife is on the floor taking orders in seating guests and the husband is
cooking and that's it.
And so it was literally like,
I grew up an only child with my parents.
And that's my family.
I mean,
a lot of people have 8 million cousins and I'm Italian,
you know,
like you figure I got a million cousins and all that.
I'm just,
I'm very lean in the family department and it felt like my mother and my father.
So right away it was a setup that felt very homey to me.
And then the husband dropped fresh pasta,
boiling hot and water hot,
the Pasta water on Basil Pesto in a giant bowl next to where I was sitting and
just tossed it and the steam wafted over.
And I just cried and I was like really going to cry,
like,
like water for chocolate,
like eat,
pray,
love.
Like I had a personal revelation and now I'm amazing.
Not at all.
It just smelled really good.
And I wanted to eat the whole bowl.
And so I ate that pasta,
like a complete savage.
I mean,
I think utensils were just kind of on the periphery of my behavior.
Um,
and he made some rabid and some other stuff and I just kind of cried a lot.
I didn't talk,
I just cried.
And I can't say food generally makes me do that.
It,
I mean,
on chopped,
I cry for different reasons.
So yeah,
that might be it.
And I liked that.
No phone,
no nothing.
You want to go,
you got to roll up.
It's not on the your GPA,
it's just God you got to really,
you know,
put some Goji berries in your pouch and climb a mountain on a loin cloth to find
this place.
Old School.
My,
um,
if any of my team through,
they know that whenever I plan off science,
I always add an activity of food tours because I am obsessed with them.
I love traveling and I feel like that's the best way to get to know a place.
Have you ever done one and a food tour?
No.
Are you anti or just never done one?
You know,
I'm going to put it to you like this.
Honestly,
it's really hard for me to have food be any more a part of my life than it
already is.
In fact,
the fight for me is to have something not food related.
You know,
people say like,
what are your hobbies that round you out and give you balance.
Like how do you find balance a,
I think that's completely unrealistic as a goal.
First of all.
Second of all,
it's definitely not happening for me and I'm not going to lie about it anymore.
This is where I've come out with the truth.
I am not a balanced human and I don't have a balanced life.
I liked my child.
I like food,
I like flowers.
I like boating and needle pointing.
Um,
so I,
I,
my desire if I have any free time is to do something that doesn't have to do
with food.
And that's hard.
Yeah.
I'm like,
oh,
we're going to a pumpkin farm in an APP,
apple orchard that's not food related.
That's my idea of kind of getting out of the kitchen and not thinking about
food.
I went to the beach yesterday.
I'm like,
I wonder what,
what is that a bluefish no matter where I am,
I find something to eat creatures to cook.
Not you
yet.
I'm sure.
Um,
but you know what I mean?
So for me,
so,
but I admire people that do and I like you a lot.
I just,
it's my favorite thing I always find I learned the most and I learned about
these off the beaten path kind of places.
And I always used to go with the first day I'm somewhere,
so I had nowhere to go.
The rest of the time getting lost.
It's wherever I am.
And finding those places.
I do that a lot.
I mean,
I was in Cleveland recently,
recently and I just found little Italy and just walked around and just wanted to
feel Italian.
Vaguely had like six can oles I figured that's what Italians are doing.
Um,
so yeah,
I understand that.
Yes.
But you mean organized tours?
Like here's where the fresh potato was cooked.
Just no,
no.
What ev of everything that you've done so far,
what have you enjoyed the most of your career?
Like the TV shows,
the executive chef part,
the cookbooks.
Honestly,
I really like,
I really,
I'm privileged to say I enjoy him almost all of what I do.
Um,
I don't like when the dishwashers are drunk and they don't show up at the
restaurant that I could do that.
I wish sometimes that I had become a plumber so that I didn't need to rely on
other people to fix stuff.
That was the math I did when I graduated from college.
Do I want to be a plumber or a chef?
And I'm like Kinda like,
it's iffy guys.
Cause it's,
they're actually the same profession,
just one has onions and one has a toilet.
So,
um,
it's maybe slightly different.
Um,
but uh,
probably,
um,
cooking in a restaurant is the thing that speaks most to me.
And I think that's why when I've been on these TV shows,
it just feels like I'm at the restaurant cooking.
And so people say,
is a camera daunting to you or whatever else.
I get so lost in the sauce that I don't feel the camera.
A lot of times when I'm competing I'll say,
get out of the way to the camera people because there'll be filming and I'll
have hot water and there's so close to me and I'm so in my planet I could,
I could hurts a camera person.
And so I say,
get out of the way.
And the,
they cut it in to make it sound like I'm saying everyone had of my way.
So I get all this mail,
like,
you know,
we just think you could be a little bit nicer
and I'm like,
you try this.
Um,
so that's been kind of funny for me.
but I get lost,
I got to say,
just pure cooking under pressure of any kind.
That's my whatever that is.
How often,
Jen,
do you still go into the restaurant?
Because I feel like you have to be so busy with the cookbook,
especially now that you're promoting it and with the TV shows you do,
where do you have time?
Fine.
I can go to the restaurant anywhere from zero to five times on any given week.
It depends.
So,
and I,
I mean generally it's the,
it varies wildly.
But I have one restaurant,
unlike a lot of other chefs,
I only have one and I've had it for 17 years.
So,
um,
it's like a family to me to go there and be in the kitchen and you know,
eaten Yogi Mac and cheese on the line and hide.
That's like one of my,
come on,
I'm at work.
I'm very busy,
so a lot.
Um,
and it's,
I can take a taxi to it from where I live.
Very important.
Um,
and I love the people.
They're better people than I am.
It's good to be around people that are better than you.
Well,
that's amazing to have had it for 17 years because so many restaurants come into
New York City and just fail.
I,
I read the review of butter before I worked there in the New York Times and I
said,
this sounds like a real happening hip joint.
I want to go there before it closes.
I read the review,
I thought that there's something.
So a friend of a friend kind of thing said,
go down there,
they're looking for a chef.
So I went there and there was like a disco ball on the ceiling and the waiter
was like,
Hey,
what do you want to eat?
And I thought in,
no,
this has nothing to do with all the experience I had had up to that point.
Um,
but I went in the kitchen and I looked at the chefs,
the cooks,
and there was one guy that was like cooking some scallops and he turned around
and he was smiling and I thought he's cooking the scallops and the vibration of
the Pan is going up his arm and making him smile because he loves it so much.
This is what I thought I saw,
you know,
in the sunlight.
She looks stunning.
So I looked at him and I saw the smile and he turned around and that was it.
I was like,
all right,
you look,
this is what's up.
I miss that.
And if it's here,
I'm going to work here.
So I took the job.
Um,
we called butter.
We can't believe it's still open for,
I come in every day like we're so clever.
Um,
but maybe if you laugh at yourself all the time and work really hard and just
keep it humble and keep moving,
maybe that works.
That gentleman cooking the scallops still works with me 17 years later and he's
like,
my child,
I'm like,
where are you going?
You've had two beers.
You're not going anywhere.
He's like,
I,
I'm old now.
Um,
but you never know.
I went on,
I really went with it.
I went someone's facial expression dictated my choice and um,
I've not been sorry since that's something that you just know,
like you have a feeling about places,
especially with work work.
Yes.
Romantic endeavors might be a little clever maneuvering those.
That's another topic we'll have Google after dark.
Um,
I will open it up to some questions now.
Does anybody dare ask a question?
I wouldn't anybody.
Alrighty.
We're all staring at your shirt.
You Judge People's food.
Yes.
So is it hard to turn off that instinct when you're eating out or just getting a
slice or,
that's a great question.
Um,
I grew up with parents.
My mother would cook from the cookbook.
She was editing and asked my father and me what we thought.
And she collected 30 years of for Maine magazine and she would say,
is this pumpkin pie better than the 1986 version from October?
Or what do you think?
Well the cross is a little bit,
so I'm going through this in my head that I did this every night of my childhood
and realize that my mother trained a chop judge by accident.
So I came from that.
I'm cut from that cloth and the answer is yes,
I can completely shut off.
And in most instances when I'm eating out,
I do imagine I go to a restaurant now and I take a sip of water and everybody
stops.
How is it?
I'm like,
it's tap water.
You guys crushed it.
So yeah,
I can shut off and really enjoy food.
The downside is no one invites me over for dinner and I have very few friends
now.
Hi,
big fan.
Thank you eva on your Instagram.
Ah,
um,
so you're on a bunch of different shows,
a lot of,
a lot of things going on and we don't get to see behind the scenes.
Can you give us any like sneak behind the scenes secrets,
especially for chopped I guess since it seems like things happen so quickly,
but how can those people really come up with something?
Oh No.
The reason the show is so good is because it's all real.
And,
and I,
I go there every time and I say,
what more can happen.
Seriously.
I go there and I am the most skeptical of all.
And like I went there,
the last episode we shot somehow someone was cooking something and it caught on
fire.
Somehow something in the Pan was flammable in an enduring way.
They threw it in the garbage can,
the garbage can caught on fire.
It was like burning.
And I'm like,
the producer just kind of looked like,
it goes over to the judges table.
Like,
cause we kind of marvel at,
um,
the humanity that is chopped.
And I think now that it's been on for a few years,
people come and they expect that even if they don't win,
they're going to have some experience and learn about themselves and grill.
And guess what they do?
They do.
And you know,
I say to people stuff like,
you know,
they're saying,
I don't know,
I can't do this.
And I said,
this is voluntary.
You came here today,
you're going to win a lot of money.
You don't want it.
That pisses us off,
you know?
And people just say,
wow,
you know,
that's cool.
You know,
you need that sit up straight kind of talk.
That's what chopped can be.
As far as behind the scenes,
I think I would just say to you that Scott Conant and I have a special
relationship with the craft services table,
which is,
you know,
the table of food that they put out for the crew does not really for us the
judges,
but if there's a jar of peanut butter and like a plate of cookies,
Scott and I'll go over and to erase the banana peel fisheye sandwich.
Just say he will just start scooping the peanut butter like,
man,
what were they thinking?
He's healing
through half a jar of peanut butter.
And I'm like,
you shouldn't eat all that peanut butter.
And I'm meeting a stack,
a sleeve of cookies.
It was up to heal.
So I sat down with the nutritionist,
wasn't one day to figure out like what's a day on top like for me?
And I figured out it's between five and 6,000 calories.
Yeah,
well I'm not going to be a swimsuit model for sure.
So,
um,
I think that's a really interesting thing.
People ask me,
how much do the judges you'd or what do you eat an often we do what I call like
healing eating.
Like I will go to something,
I have always known to be good and I will eat this and all will be healed in the
land and it works.
But you know,
then you get elastic weight,
waist pants,
you know,
so that's the trade off.
Um,
I would say to you behind the scenes on chopped the open the basket,
Ted says your time starts now and they start cooking and there's no extra like,
wait,
stop,
go blah,
blah,
blah.
Nothing.
And I think that's how you get these visceral experiences.
Um,
they did have a light blow out once when they were about to start cooking.
So it took them about five or six minutes to change the bulb.
They changed the basket because they had had five minutes.
And I think those types of truths on the show really make it what it is.
The other thing I want to say is that that Bobby flay man on B,
both lay people are like,
oh my God,
how's he went all the time.
It's so fake,
please.
I'm like,
how did you win again?
So annoying.
I've said he really does it,
but I've seen him lose.
He loses.
Yeah.
I like when he loses something like Tacos.
I'm like,
aren't you sorry.
He's like,
shut up.
This is your last episode.
Those are my,
yeah,
sure.
It's the eating.
I guess that's the behind the scenes.
Are you laughing at
to begin the Kava toppy out butter is one of my favorite things in the world.
Thank you.
Thank you for introducing that into my life.
Um,
so considering the culinary world is definitely a male dominated industry as a
prominent woman in the field,
what advice would you have for young professional women who are considering
starting their careers?
Is that,
you know,
with my sister though,
his sister
imaginary,
your friend,
just googling me.
I might go,
I mean,
you're an only child.
I get this question a lot.
I,
I'm going to write the,
the proper answer in a book,
but until I do that,
I'll say off the cuff,
which I'll regret later.
Um,
probably I just always ignored gender and,
and I think that in a gender fluid time where I think we're really questioning
gender roles,
I mean things like referring to yourself as they instead of he or she,
I think I was mentally referred to myself as a we and the we,
that was all the little characters in my personal play that gave me the
confidence to stand in the kitchen with 27 men and cook all those years and be
bad at it and be vulnerable and whatever else.
Um,
I just ignored it.
I just thought this is just part of the school yard.
You know,
I,
you know,
I find,
both genders can be cruel in their own way.
I'm sure you would agree.
Um,
but I really ignored that.
I just thought I want to be an expert and I want to be good at it and this is
what I have to do.
And that,
that stuff was hard sometimes.
So is learning how to butcher a side of beef.
You know,
it wasn't just the people that was hard.
It was all the work that I had to master or try to master.
Um,
so ignore it and be as polite as you possibly can.
Do you ever see the movie Roadhouse,
Patrick Swayze?
Probably not.
There's a whole talk in there,
you know,
he's a cooler,
like he's a bouncer and all these different places.
I want to hire him to just fix my life,
which is a little late for that.
But um,
he says be nice until it's time not to be nice,
you know,
and he has this whole Chit Chat.
Some of you have seen the movie,
I'm sure.
I hope.
Thank you.
Thank you dad.
You know,
something like that.
Um,
just keep it inside,
keep it moving,
stay polite and
mm.
Try to be the best in the room.
And then that generally makes everything else not matter.
Even if you don't end up the best.
People respect you for effort and hard work.
I don't think anybody can ignore that,
if that makes sense.
And then sometimes all that just doesn't work and it just sucks also.
Um,
but ignore,
hit delete,
move on.
Yeah.
Hi.
Um,
I really like chopped.
And you as a judge,
thanks.
What you think is like the funniest or most memorable moment on the show.
No one's ever asked me that.
No one ever asks me what's funny.
I've never been asked that.
What's funny?
Not much.
Um
hmm.
I mean the funniest things to me are um,
being on an episode with Jeffrey and Scott on either side of me.
That is the,
the,
the TRIFECTA.
The three of us.
Like we have some special bond.
I like watching Jeff and Scott Bicker over who's wearing a nicer suit
and they'll keep it going.
I mean,
we sit there for 10,
12 hours.
Oh Wow.
You know,
that's a la us a lot of thread count talk.
Um,
but the two of them,
they make me laugh the most really?
That that would have to be it.
Yeah.
They're just unbelievable.
And he's like,
do you see this?
And I'm like,
I just can't hold thing.
And your thing.
And Jeffrey is stratospheric mean,
you know now I've gotten,
Marcus Samuelsson is sort of like a competing fashion icon and I'm like,
Marcus,
I think you addressed this so well.
He really does.
I'm like,
mark,
I think you look a little nicer than Jeffrey today.
And Jeffery's like,
excuse me,
he's literally like a peacock,
like fanning has feathers.
So I enjoyed that with all that vanity is so much humility and intelligence that
it's fun.
But then they cracked me up the most.
Definitely.
So,
uh,
since you don't get invited out to eat ever,
if you ever want to come over me and my wife will happily have you over just
one.
Got It done.
You will be judged silently.
I feel pretty confident in my skills.
I'm an amateur.
I feel bad.
Take care of that.
Buildings crumbling.
Out of all of the dishes that you've ever had,
therapist said,
I can ignore you
the best one that you've had so far on junk.
Yeah.
Best,
best one.
The one that made you go ahead.
There's a couple.
Yeah,
there's a couple people usually ask me the worst.
You guys are so sunshiny the funniest small man.
What's your favorite dish?
People like what's discussing?
Tell us.
I asked you that.
Um,
yeah,
there was a dish.
I th I literally think it's season one.
It does a dessert.
And while I don't remember everything about it,
it was,
uh,
the person made a shortcake biscuit,
like a cream drop biscuit and they had to use pickled ginger and pickled grape
leaves.
The whole basket was like vinegar,
salt bomb.
And they made like a,
like a basically a shortcake with all these savory ingredients.
And it was just perfect.
And I remember,
I think I said to the producer,
is it okay if I say this is perfect and that I have no criticism?
And she said yes,
no.
Um,
but almost.
And that dish,
yeah,
that's my favorite one.
I had another one recently that was pretty good,
but I can't tell you about it.
I've also had,
um,
some really rough moments like period hot dogs,
raw and French toast.
Yeah.
Sounds delicious.
Yeah,
I'll be serving it in the lounge after it.
So,
yeah.
Thank you.
Great question.
Hi.
Hi here.
Yes.
What is your favorite New York City grocery store to get lost in and spend a lot
of these questions.
You guys are so smart.
I wasn't ready for this,
really.
My favorite.
Hmm.
I love so many.
I have to honest,
it's not a grocery store,
but my favorite place to get lost hands down is the union square green market.
I start on Park Avenue and 17th Street and I just curve my way.
It's basically horseshoe shaped and I just curve my way all around.
That's my favorite grocery store.
I know it's not brick and mortar in the classical sense,
but you know,
I can eat five apple cider donuts and 14 muffins and,
and people are like,
oh,
it's so healthy.
The green market like Zucchini.
Where's the fun in that?
Let me tell you again,
have a 10,000 calorie moment making that loop if you work hard.
Um,
and I like,
I really like keeping abreast of what farmers are making,
what in the tristate area.
I mean a lot of it is obviously New York,
some New Jersey.
Um,
I really like keeping up on what people are making and producing.
And I buy that and we serve so much of that at butter,
you know,
and I don't have like a wall of farmers with a picture of a cow and we don't
have any of that stuff.
We just buy the stuff and serve it.
Cause that's,
I feel as much as a restaurant is able to do that within their means.
To me,
that's what a restaurant should do.
So that's my favorite.
Um,
yeah,
sure.
I was,
I wish I had an even better answer.
Damage.
Yes.
Last three questions.
Yeah.
So stressed out.
Who would you most prefer to have a cook you a meal
of all of the chefs and cooks that you've met?
MMM,
God,
I'm like sweating.
I got a lot of friends and,
but I got some enemies.
I gotta I gotta
probably,
you know,
I mean a wacky headspace.
Um,
I'd probably like Morimoto to cook me a giant Japanese feast or Rick Bayless
Cook.
We a huge Mexican feast.
That's kind of where my head is.
You asked me in two months and I'll pick someone French and someone you know
from South America,
but right now that'd probably be it.
I really also want and Sophie Pink.
I mentioned her earlier when we get to pick one though.
Stop it
worse.
Um,
yeah.
Morimoto I'm going to go with Rick Bayless for today.
I'm a I'm moody though.
Yeah.
Hi
I,
oh I loved you on job.
Thank you.
Only on chopped you notice that?
That's the one I'm watching those.
So like I'm obsessed with the food network.
Like it plays in the background of my house all the time and like I love like
eating out and I love home cooking but like basically I hate cooking when I sell
because it stresses me out.
Like there's like too many things that can go wrong and if I try and follow a
recipe like really stresses me out because I'm worried that I'm going to
overcook something but I would like to be good at like I would like to cook
despite hating it right now.
So do you want to have it?
Can I like,
do you have suggestions for like starting out,
like home cooking?
Like easy things to make or like recipe books?
I mean I guess you're selling it
right?
Things that are good to start out to make it less stressful.
Oh honey.
Uh,
is there someone in your family has a really good cook?
My Dad's a really good cut.
Did he do all the cooking while you were growing up?
Uh,
yeah.
So it was a kitchen was like his,
yeah,
like my mom can't and my mom can't like boiling it.
Right.
I was just getting the vibe that someone was very territorial about the kitchen
you grew up in and that you then as a result enjoyed all this great eating but
maybe didn't exactly have the space to build some confidence,
cook more.
But I just like,
I don't know,
it's,
it was seems stressful.
Well this bar was too high.
I was like,
if I cook it's not going to be as good as that.
So like
we said the same thing.
You just said it in a different
[inaudible] very expensive mind you're talking to my therapist is living in a
yacht
and I am read tiling her third pool.
Um,
your dad's not coming over to your food unless you invite him.
So there's that to think about,
right?
I would say start with an egg.
You can boil an egg,
but you can also fry it.
Poach it.
Steam at bay,
get roasted,
scramble.
You can do a lot of stuff with an egg.
And I think if you take the one ingredient and you just master all the things
you can do with it,
um,
it really,
it's a great confidence builder.
I always say eggs and they're really easy to screw up.
The real easy to cook and they're really easy to screw up.
And so if you can just fry an egg every day,
just heal honey.
That's right.
He'll say,
I'm going to put these eggs into a cake and a souffle and a meatball and a
meatloaf.
And then all of a sudden you're cooking and then you invite your dad over for
dinner and you're like,
excuse me,
my house.
And then the last question I once dropped all the time and sometimes I wonder is
as judges you play good cop,
bad cop.
Like it flows so much your,
your comments where you know someone might slam someone but then someone else
jumps in and says this is this like do you have to do you,
are you aware of that or do you feel bad ever if you're all three of you just
no,
no to all of that.
I know what you mean.
And some days I'm like,
you were so awful today.
And then some days I'm like,
you're such a great buff but we don't do that on purpose.
And we don't ever say like,
okay dude you do this and I'll do that.
Okay you take this and you,
I'll take that.
It just flows and know that's the,
the good fortune of fantastic accidental relationships between all the chop
judges.
And I find like,
you know,
I'll say I disagree in Jeffery's.
Like,
of course you disagree with me.
So he feels like I always disagree with him,
which I pretty much do.
Um,
but no,
that's all organic.
That stuff.
Yes.
I feel bad sometimes.
I wish,
I feel angry when someone doesn't do well.
That's great.
And that doesn't get portrayed right when it gets twisted through the lens of a
TV.
Um,
or sometimes I'm very transparent with somebody and people write me like,
y'all saw me and I hate jail.
So when I got my first hate mail,
I called my dad.
I was like,
nobody likes me.
Like clutching a can of paint thinner.
I'm like,
and my dad's like,
I think you're starting to really make it.
If someone doesn't like you,
that was very helpful.
Yeah.
The,
yeah.
And then I called my mom and she's like,
don't do those shows.
You're really bad at them.
So I've got alive a lots of workout.
Um,
but all that's just organic and I think that's why it's so great.
Yes.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for thanks for listening.
[inaudible] finding books that ups the stairs there.